informatics conference that
uh normally takes place on thursdays at
11 30.
um
some of our uh meetings have returned to
in person
and um but since uh our speakers are not
in portland today uh we will uh have
them speak to us remotely um and even in
the in-person sessions we've also been
um
broadcasting them by webex however today
is actually a twofer and let me just
look at my calendar here so
this afternoon
at four o'clock
as a
offering that's part of our demise
diversity equity inclusion and
anti-racism journal club we're going to
hear from dr leslie king
um who um
has a very interesting story
um and
the title of her talk is a black woman
physician's experiences in rural oregon
and beyond um a she's a hunter fisher
trapper
etc
that uh event will actually be live for
those who want to attend in the big
theater i will be there
for those of you who know my backgrounds
i'm i'm at home now but i will be going
to the office this afternoon
and i will take part in that
so today's session is something we have
recently
implemented
which is a
hearing from our alumni
we um
have a very illustrious and highly
accomplished alumni
um who come into the program from a
variety of backgrounds and and go out
and do great things
and so we decided that we would um
devote some of our conferences to a
panel like experience where they would
um give us a
a brief not too brief but um overview of
what they're doing in their career
and maybe reflecting a little bit on
their
time in the program
and so we have three speakers today
um i would like to ask each of them to
limit their speaking to about 15 minutes
it's up to them whether they have slides
or not
and and then we'll leave a little bit of
time for questions both to individuals
and maybe
discussion of the group
so i'm um
going to follow the order that is in
the um
outlook invitation that lynn sent
so and and i'm not going to
provide a lot of uh
introductory background like i often do
just just so we can focus our time on
the speakers
so um our first speaker is um someone
that probably most if not all of you
know
well she um is um
actually is a
a research associate in the department
um information one
and and information one is her
classification according to the new ohsu
classification
and um
she's a graduate of our master's program
and and continues to work both as a kind
of uber ta and then also on various
research projects and
kate is also
very active
nationally
internationally i'm always getting
accolades from my colleagues she did
such a great job helping edit the
yearbook or some
article
or
being on a program committee of anemia
conference so i will um let kate
go ahead and i note that it is 11 35 a.m
pacific time so okay
all right let me try to share this
okay
can everybody see this
yes
okay um thank you bill um i tell you
my name is kate faltollis i graduated
from
um
ohsu in 2016.
and what i'm going to talk today i'm
going to do a little bit about my
background but i'm also going to talk
about
what bill mentioned
managing and editing an international
biomedical informatics journal with an
ohsu masters in biomedical informatics
um
so one of the things i wanted to do was
do the land acknowledgement that we
we've been doing
i know up at ohsu but i live in los
angeles and work remotely for ohsu
demise is so called
the ohsu
d mice los angeles office and
i live on land that's um from the
sangha
and
about a block away from my house is a
running spring that has been occupied
for
over 8 000 years and so i just want to
give
that acknowledgement to where i live and
the people that have been here before
now my background in brief i was born in
chicago grew up in hyde park which is in
the south side and my family members
were in education government
i studied
18th century literature of chicago and
minored in biological sciences
after i left chicago i worked at harvard
medical school and a variety of
different jobs and then ucla primarily
interested in
medical research
funding and grants
and while i was at ucla i got a ms from
the library school at the university of
illinois just
it was online and i could um
i could work
on it and also go on campus so i went to
illinois
a couple times a year to finish that
masters
and then i obtained the mbi in um
by biomedical informatics i think that's
the master's non-thesis now
in 2016.
i've always had an interest in
biomedical publications and one thing
i've been very interested in is going to
amia summits and
conferences and
when i attended the summits in 2013 i
met chris layman
and he told me about
working on med info in 2013 as for as a
student project and they were
doing you know they were um getting
students to
write
or
edit
proceedings for med info med info is the
big international conference
that's held um every other year
um it will be in sydney australia next
year
and what was nice about this project is
that they um they
i got
you know the senior editorship in it and
also
all student editors were paid
for their work which is unusual for
volunteer work
when dr layman became president of
international medical informatics
association in 2016 he asked me to be a
so-called chief editor of the emea
yearbook in 2018
and under the senior editorship of
brigitte cerro c
now
what is emia what is what is the
international medical informatics
association in your book and
as i said on my first slide
it takes like 180 days to produce um and
so i
yo i i wanted to give you a sense of
what this was it's um was started in
1992
um
the the one the yearbook shown here is
um the 2021 yearbook on managing
pandemics
which is very well done um
and then since 2014 the yearbook
publishes in our online and open source
format
there are 12 sections each with a survey
paper and best papers
so
you're spending roughly six months to
produce a survey paper idea to final
paper and 15 papers
in each section there's 12 sections
it's their split between myself and
fleur milk
in france and i
i list on the right here my sections um
human factors and organizational issues
decision support
these are very
um
very well organized sections and and
they have
they have section editors use usually
two
sometimes three
um
people edit
looking for the best survey in that area
in the last year
or two
and also 15
papers
i've highlighted decision support is
because i have an opening
if you're if you're interested and i'm
going to put in the chat the the the
website but um i have an opening in
decision support
section editor right now
um
this year we're doing um inclusive
digital health addressing equity
literacy and bias for resilient health
systems
and every year at the april editorial
meeting editors choose a theme for
upcoming yearbook and for 2022 the theme
was inclusive digital health
um
actually i'm going to put the website on
the chat when i can look at it and um
here's a list of some of the survey
papers um there that we're just we're
just finishing this right now and
we are going to be doing next year uh
the focus is going to be on one health
which is more to do with environmental
issues um climate change and health
among other things
now here's the thing that is my big plug
we need your reviewers reviewers or
viewers every year we need you we need
people
professionals to help review survey
papers and help determine best papers
chosen by section editor the review the
service papers is a lot of work
the less so for the best papers because
there's really short reviews but we we
need you
um we need more survey paper providers
for all the sections and everything is
indexed in pubmed and everything is very
very
i think very well edited
um we need interest in helping section
editors with subject searching and
identification of survey writers and
many people who help out become section
editors and it's very prestigious
finally did i mention reviewers it's
just kind of like an ongoing thing to
to find reviewers um
and
also
you know that
if you're interested in any of the areas
that that we cover um
always need help with um
with searching and things like that
now
one of the advantages to being
a section editor is that um there's a
yearly meeting of all the editors all
the section editors and the chief
editors and fleur and myself and paris
um
and this is at the um
the
down here so it's the it's the
university of rene descartes where the
laboratory informatique medical a danger
described
it's basically the biomedical
informatics department of the university
of cerebons
medical school
and it's held there
and that was um that was kind of like
the the upper
the photos of that and
we always have a lot of fun
this is like a full day it was about
10 hours
maybe more like eight or nine hours of
reviewing all those
survey papers and best papers
for um the 2019
um yearbook
now
as all of us know we had a pandemic and
um
that's this is what the virtual meeting
looked like
a couple of last week or april 29th
and
you see everybody looks kind of i look
pretty tired i think i think this is
computer information systems and uh it
was like
five in the morning for me so
uh they they run it on on paris time and
next to me is um is the senior editor
lina soumaya and then these guys in the
um
and the green box are on their boat
so they um they did their presentation
of cis section in
while they were on holiday
in switzerland and so they gave a
presentation from their boat which i
thought was like kind of oh well this is
kind of fun we got to see like
a little bit of the mountains too so
so that's kind of
um you know where
where um where the emea yearbook is at
um
and
i wanted just to end my presentation
with this is my dad as i mentioned was
at the university of chicago in the
department of meteorology and he was
this is his hydro laboratory
and then i thought you know i must have
become
an okay editor because um because i did
an editorial assessment at my dad's
laboratory when i was fought when i was
three and it's kind of really very
accurate
as my mother says
um
[Music]
so that's it and um
i'm gonna stop sharing this
and
let me know if you have any questions
great thank you um
for your presentation and um
as one who has made occasional
contributions to the yearbook over the
years it's yeah important um service for
our field does anyone have any questions
for kate
yeah you know and you can always email
me
um if you're interested
uh we have a lot we
have a lot going on it's really a fun
it's a fun thing to work on um
so
well thanks kate um
i um
[Music]
i encourage um
people who are interested to
review it it's a great experience to um
and it you know makes a contribution it
makes um
those uh resources better
the editors all the all the section
editors are really wonderful to work
with and maybe you get to go on verner
and um alex's boat in switzerland so so
so
great well good why don't we um move on
to our next speaker
well everyone is a graduate of the
program that's why they're on this panel
dr ron jimenez who
i remember back
it's been a while since he's been in the
program um but he has certainly gone on
and
done great things he he has also
contributed um to
some of the research projects
that um that we've taken place as a um
uh a um
[Music]
relevance judge for those of you who
know what that is but anyways um uh
ron is a physician
a graduate of usc keck school of
medicine
he has trained in pediatrics he's a
active practitioner
he was in the early
cohort of the program
and when he's not
practicing as an urgent care pediatric
urgent care physicians at palo alto
medical foundation he is the ceo of a
company called codescribe which i
imagine we might hear about
so take it away ron
thank you bill i appreciate that very
much and i'm really happy to be here and
share a little bit about my trajectory
and we'll talk about that a little bit
so um i don't have the chat window up
but i'll certainly uh be available for
questions afterwards and can answer
anything at that point
why am i doing this um
when i was uh
asked about this i thought you know what
do i have to contribute to this
well i've got a narrative i've got a
story and so this is just kind of one
retrospective view of a career but
really what i want to do is sort of
share what's possible share
some encouragement um for anybody who's
struggling professionally because i
certainly did along the way
um as an aide to decision making
you know this was wholly unexpected by
me and you'll see why in just a little
bit and really to say thank you
um to all the folks at ohsu who have
been there and who have really been
supportive i won't list off all the
names you can read them quicker than i
can say them um i'm deeply grateful to
all of them
and continue to be grateful and still
having a lot of fun doing some of that
work on
the projects so please keep me in mind
um trajectory um i looked it up in
cambridge and i really didn't want to be
thought of as being shot into the air
so i looked it up again in
merriam-webster and this sounded a
little bit more appropriate path
progression line of development
resembling a physical trajectory it's
kind of felt that way
and i want to sort of describe a little
bit about that trajectory and and what
it's encompassed
but first i want to talk about failures
failures give success perspective and so
i wanted that to be my first slide i had
to repeat a year of medical school a
whole lot of reasons why not important
when everybody else was at match day and
getting their you know their envelopes i
was frantically on the phone trying to
find a position because i didn't match
ended up with a med peds internship at
ellie county usc
during that first year i quit for a few
days i had a really really really bad
call night and if anybody wants to know
about i'm happy to share it but wasn't
pretty
rather than quit completely i was
convinced by my
by my director to finish up which was
absolutely the right thing to tell me
and i finished up at ucsf's
program in fresno and finished in
pediatrics there
the program when i got there was on
probation
and i thought this is not a good idea
program got recertified with flying
colors
the last failure is going to come in
important here in just a little bit i
applied to the stanford design school
after residency
um met with ralph fausti and and david
kelly from ido
and i was denied admission to the
program they basically said you have the
wrong degree
we don't really need an md we need an me
degree
we parted ways and
i'll tell a story later about david
kelly in just a bit
this is now known as the d school of the
house of platinum institute of design at
stanford
what does this climb look like oh my
gosh years and years
but really well worth it um
keck school of medicine la county usc
ucsf and fresno valley children's in
fresno now in madeira
urgent care pediatric practice for a few
years when i was first trying to get my
get my sea legs if you will in practice
worked in community clinics worked at a
startup called physician access
which had a handheld
electronic medical record
long before
ipads and other things
then i worked at santa clara valley
health and hospital system which was the
public hospital system for silicon
valley which has since grown quite a bit
was there for almost 20 years
during that time i worked at as a
consultant for hamilton hmc
consulting a company that was really
really very
helpful in terms of seeing how to apply
what i had learned
i went on to work for stanford for a
couple of years in the medical
informatics department worked for epic
as an epic emeritus if you all don't
know what that is that's just someone
who's
old and been on epic for a while and can
give some advice
after that i worked for a company called
sagacious which was a startup of about
when i joined it was about
70 people i guess and grew to about uh
oh roughly 300 then it was acquired by
accenture so i stayed with extension for
a few years and really enjoyed that time
with accenture currently i'm with palo
alto medical foundation sutter and a
number of years ago founded this company
quote scrub which i'll talk a little bit
about later
climbing up this curve um
how did i end up in medical informatics
one might ask
well it started with
discovering that what i really wanted to
do most of my life was something called
product design
and i realized that because i saw a
nightline episode way way back
and i learned about david kelly and ido
ideo was a company that had just been
formed at that time it was id2 and david
kelly designs dkd
and they were doing what was termed the
architecture of products
or product design um
things have gone on and evolved to
include human-centered design and design
thinking which really evolved david
kelly
if you all are interested in who david
kelly is and what he has to say go find
him on ted talks he and i had a great
laugh when i came back 20 some odd years
later and
thanked him for denying me admission so
that i went on to do medical informatics
we had a good laugh about it and he
invited me to come speak
during the time i was just in practice i
was given a mac uh to transcribe all of
my clinical notes so i wouldn't use the
transcription service
um
and i pretty much self-taught my you
know self-taught myself all of the stuff
i needed to know to do that and then got
really curious about computers and that
was really in the early days of medical
informatics in fact bill i don't know if
you're going to want to comment or not
but we were kicking around whether we
were informaticians and whether it was
clinical informatics or biomedical
informatics or medical informatics and
there was a lot of a lot of great
discussion at that time but
i found this program back in 2001 gosh
has been that long
the distance learning program and we did
not have video chat it was all done on
blackboard and bulletin boards and chat
and
the fascinating thing was we really got
to know each other very very well
and realized who had different talents
and skills
very quickly it was a great experience i
really enjoyed it
i think back then we were on blackboard
i'm not even sure i want to remember
that
let's see here
during the time
i came out of that experience i realized
i could do a lot in the environment
which i was in and this is just a sample
of some of the stuff i got to do
barcode
immunization entry and form development
i was part of the california
immunization registry pretty much at its
formation and back in the days when we
would run around to different clinics
taking floppy disks and
installing the application and taking
data and giving data and this was just
just pre-internet
i was a medical informatics director for
santa clara valley for a number of years
and was responsible for all of the
systems their support and integration
for all the contracts as well i did
quite a bit of work in contracts and
came to work with a lot of great
attorneys at that time and a lot gained
a lot of great experience
during that time i co-developed a web
portal which integrated a bunch of
disparate
systems into a single window and
basically allowed any of our physicians
at the time to find what they needed
with a medical record number and a name
and that was it
a lot of
handoffs behind the scenes and some
really interesting work that we actually
published on which was fun
titles
let's not read all of these titles the
only reason i included this slide was
really to say
if you're an informatics you're going to
wear a lot of different hats over the
years
and the titles don't really tell you
what you're what's going on and what
you're doing the titles are really
following what the need is in any one of
these organizations
for me culminating in the in the
consultant roles
and currently in the ceo role
wouldn't be a good talk about success
unless i talked about the peaks and
these are the peaks for me if anybody
can recognize that that's the front side
of
mount whitney
14494 yes i've been there once in my
life probably will never go back
but happy to say i've been there at
least once
publishing
hosting a poster there at amia
um
getting and being invited to to
participate in in dr ash's work in
publishing i got to write a chapter on a
case study which was just wonderful
enjoyed that very much
um
bill you will remember sitting next to
me at the cohort
first cohort induction ceremony and i
the word that came to mind was surreal
um how should i be sitting next to bill
hirsch at this event
um it was very humbling and then most
recently um
our patent i'll talk about that a little
bit
we patented a method for
um training cpr using augmented reality
it's been a great experience it was
granted just last march um
although it covers augmented reality
virtual reality and mixed reality it
really is about ar primarily
and part of this patent which made it
very interesting was that it included a
scenario generation engine
and we were informed by our patent
attorneys this is termed a
fundamental patent
meaning there is nothing like it out
there and the best line i like is from
the patent office which is the prior
artist silent there was nothing they
could find that referenced anything we
were writing about and therefore we have
a lot more work to do in terms of the
adjacent intellectual property
um so what does it mean to be a
practicing physician a ceo
it means you're really not retiring
although i'm retiring from
more active participation in
pediatrics come july i'm going to be
doing some more informatics consulting
and really spending more time with
codescribe we're incorporating literally
as we speak
we have uh two patents in uh well we
have one granted one pending uh we have
two more patents which are contemplated
we're seeking funding we're looking for
partnerships and licensing
and if there's anyone out there who is
an ar kit
person and wants a project i have
something very juicy for you to work on
these are all my contact information if
anybody has any questions
or would be interested in just talking
some more about any of this i'm also
available if anybody has any questions
about sort of this path and this
trajectory
and and how to how to move along in
medical informatics and really have a
great time doing it
great
thanks
um
tell us maybe a little bit about
transition from um
um
you know more kind of
practice work to
start up company although i guess you've
actually been involved in a number of
companies along the way
um
how do you um how is that similar
different you know from other kinds of
activities
um the big crossover is leaving the
bedside and the the magic word is
culture
um
one leaves you know the physician
culture goes into the business and
consulting world and it is a different
world that's probably the biggest leap
um
it has been um
interesting to look back on all of that
and see how all of the things i did
before built on
um on informatics training contributed
um even to the point where
you know
going back to ideo and having you know
getting invited by david keller to come
speak at his graduate programs
so um
that's probably the biggest thing is
recognizing
how everything built on what i learned
in that distance learning program
without video chat which was just
fascinating to me yeah so if you were in
the certificate program we we taught our
first online course bmi 510 in 1999
and um
then launched the certificate program
like the following year so you were a
very early
cohort
but
through the process you've also been uh
inducted into um femia
actually kate is also uh
has been elected to femiah
and in fact
while you were talking i just can't
resist
um
this is the um can you all see that
this is the first
first um induction ceremony of the
fellows of amia
um
and uh you see some other
probably well-known faces there
you see ron on the end um
you see jody kotischwax adam wright in
the back
um
carolyn peterson
um
and um others
um
and um actually i will be attending this
year's themia induction ceremony because
it always takes place at the clinical
informatics conference which
i'm hoping will take place in two weeks
if we manage to keep covet under control
but i will be there um
and um and you've also you know like
many physicians who have graduated the
program achieve board certification
which is great
um any um any other questions
um for
for ron
hey ronna well i have to ask you and how
do you like trek
um it's wonderful i have i you know
pushing it
no no we learned early on
that we have very odd definitions of fun
i really enjoy
not only getting oriented to what the
year's objectives are
but developing a methodology to to get
through it
um it really has evolved nicely and you
know i've i've looked back and thought
i can see how this has worked out and
has been helpful so i really enjoyed it
quite a bit and would encourage anybody
who has any interest in
sort of learning how the the nuts and
bolts of of informatics work in terms of
creating
create essentially a service in terms of
finding things in terms of locating
things information retrieval um
that has a very practical application i
actually can see the
see the utility of it quite well
and and for those who who don't know
what trek is trek is the text retrieval
conference and many of you do know that
um
i i'm involved in it's a information
retrieval challenge evaluation that's
actually sponsored by nist the national
institute for standards and technology
and um
they create these test collections that
people who do information retrieval
research can use
they're meant to be reusable
they they're part of this annual
challenge but then they become enduring
resources and research groups use them
to test their systems to see how well
they do how they can improve things and
so forth um but you need a gold standard
for those things um in in and um um
because nist doesn't have any clinical
people in its employ um they outsource
that to to us to ohsu and and kate is
the cat herder
who um
uh uh gets uh gets people um
um involved and and doing the work and
um and people like ron and other
graduates of the program and and
students in the program who have
clinical expertise because it really is
a clinical judgment task
the the up the output of the process is
an informatics tool but we we actually
need clinical experts to say this
article is relevant for this task and so
forth and
um so
it's been great that you've been able to
do that any other questions from
uh the group
change is interested in
your
website and email so he'll likely follow
up with you uh chengdu is one of our
clinical informatics fellows
and um
i'm good um
any other
questions
if not we will
move to the third and um final speaker
for today's session
another physician another pediatrician
dr eric kirkendall
who did the program a little later than
dr jimenez did it
he too has gone on to an illustrious
informatics career as associate chief
medical information officer at
cincinnati children's um and now um
he uh helps lead the uh wake forest
center for health care innovation at
wake forest university which um i've
followed this initiative from afar i
find it very interesting um
and so he has his um also like kate has
his master of biomedical informatics um
and um uh he's going to tell us some
about his work
thanks dr hirsch um so uh pleasure to be
here it's great to be back virtually uh
in presenting kind of telling my story a
little bit uh i'm good i have slides
that i'll share in a second um just to
kind of round out my bio a little bit
more um we can make it a clean sweep on
the the femia recognition so i think i
was in the second class
so
a highlight of my career as well being
nominated and receiving
that recognition um i think just
i want to talk more about the center and
my work uh but i'll just say a little
bit about my path at first just so
everybody can kind of hear
that story a little bit
um
so i started off i i was very fortunate
in the early days
you know training in a world-class
institution at cincinnati children's
i was a pediatric hospitalist so working
always in the hospital
didn't really have an office per se
clint
and i got really interested in uh
pursuing additional training and kind of
getting uh my work portfolio a little
bit more diverse and working on things
that had a little bit different um
trajectory and goals than my clinical
work and so i
it was very fortuitous but one of the
first people i was put in contact with
when i said i was interested in what
technology and medicine could do was was
peter embi who at the time was a
rheumatologist across the street at the
adult hospital at university of
cincinnati and so i still clearly
remember talking to peter early on and
uh i did not have i knew i was getting
valuable advice that day but uh that may
have changed the uh the course of my uh
my career here without recognizing it
but peter gave me great advice i
enrolled in the distance learning
program um really really enjoyed that
and the early days really my
job was focused on a lot of operational
information so we were going through the
whole design implement evaluation
process with with our electronic health
record at cincinnati children's
started off in clinical decision support
role and then grew up and became the
associate chief medical
information officer there and then moved
to wake forest in my current position
because a really unique opportunity
opened up to
um and my career had kind of been
morphing over the years from operational
to more and more research and then into
the innovation space and so that's kind
of my my background in a
in a nutshell um i'm gonna switch over
to my slides here and
uh
as per usual i um i commit the cardinal
sin of having too much information on
the slides so um i might be flying
through these a little bit quickly
uh and skipping over a few of them but
um
we are very fortunate here uh to to have
you know started the center at the right
time in the right place uh this is a
picture of winston-salem uh and the
revitalization that's happened downtown
like it has in a lot of cities uh but
there were a lot of these facilities uh
which our offices are in have been
renovated these are a lot of old rj
reynolds um factory buildings in the
south
um and so we moved in and made that our
home and now we've got a very unique and
interesting space to work out of
um i'm going to give you a little bit of
overview of the center and what we do
within the center talk about a couple of
projects i always like to ground the
high level things into practical work
and what we work on in a day to day and
then happy to take any questions or q a
here at the end
so the center for healthcare innovation
you can see our vision and mission um
written here on the slide i won't go
through and read every everything on
here but really the the mission for us
is to um and really is the the end goal
is to reach for the improving
population health enhancing patient
experience reducing costs and improving
care provider work life so all the sort
of quadruple aim of health care kind of
things
and very quickly we realized that we um
to do so we needed to leverage the
talents and capabilities of our people
first and foremost
our digital health tools and then our
science engine and our healthcare
delivery system
and so the center was really born we're
now
about four years in uh it's a really new
center still
but it was born from the recognition
that we really needed more mechanisms to
move our science and our research and
external innovations into clinical
practice and to do so more nimbly
and a lot of this may sound familiar for
those of you who are familiar with the
concept of learning health systems and
so forth as that's been formalizing
there's a lot of parallels
and i think one thing that sort of
underscores that mission of translating
things into practice
is the fact that our funding sources
come from both sides so it comes from
the school medicine and the health care
system and so we've got
many many sets of executive sponsors but
sort of two big buckets of them
uh and then increasingly as our our work
has grown and we've scaled things out
we're recognizing and formalizing
relationship with some industry
innovation leaders to help us accelerate
the process because there are some
things that start off and
as we hit milestones and have more
success with that we quickly lose
bandwidth to make them move as fast as
what we'd like and so some external
partners are key there i think everybody
has probably heard about the 17-year
time frame of implementing
strong scientific evidence into practice
our goal for a number of things is a
vast oversimplification but our goal is
to find and identify those things
integrate those into practice and
evaluate it within five years
um and then we have other things that
have time frames that are closer to six
to twelve months and then other things
that are more of a
you know five to ten years
road map
our projects within the center are very
heterogeneous um we have probably about
20 or so projects now depending on how
you uh
count them
but i always like to look at them in a
problem solution value framework that's
the one unifying thing across all so
this is kind of the framework i've built
over time to help people
in a visual way understand what it is we
do
and then this also permeates down to how
we decide on what we work on in our
intake process
so
is the thing being proposed is it a
solution in search of a problem or is it
a reasonable problem with a reasonable
solution that we think is going to
generate value so at the end point the
right side of this slide is really what
we really measure
and as we move things through the
process we adopt a project or a program
and we accelerate it
it moves down this golden arrow which
i've just sort of referred to as the
translational innovation arrow and we're
moving a potential value to actual value
that we can measure and realize
and then you see at the bottom also this
concept of moving discovery and the
knowledge that we're generating either
internally or externally and applying
that to practice and evaluating it so
again just the one slide sort of visual
to underscore
uh the work we do we pride ourselves in
being a center that is very intentional
and our philosophy around membership is
such that uh we don't try to generate
the world's largest uh listserv uh email
list serve we bring members into the
center
and we're not being exclusionary but we
bring members into the center that are
working on the projects that are within
our portfolio and we've got a pretty
diverse portfolio we're really a project
a project centric center
so you can see some of the numbers there
we also pride ourselves on being not
just for faculty so staff and and
clinical frontline folks and researchers
all across the board so if you've got a
good idea uh and it aligns with what we
the the priorities of the center and
what we want to work on then we often
adopt it no matter who you are
and then at the end again you're down at
the bottom you just see a few of our
numbers over the last year
in the the output from the center
i'm not going to dig into the details
too much but i'm i'm sort of the face of
our center today i'm the deputy director
but you see a number of the other key
folks in our leadership here and their
diverse backgrounds so uh jeff is a
geriatrician so between he and i we
cover the entire lifespan
which is sometimes interesting being a
pediatrician working on geriatric
projects but
nick piesky is our our biostats and data
science expert
paul yelton someone i recruited to help
run our technology development program
here in the center and then jen mccraw
is key as well as uh her she has a
clinical background an mba and she uh
has been out in industry before and so
now she's our director of strategy
and we've got a whole host of other
folks who are part of our core team who
on a daily basis spend
50 to 100 of their time here working in
the center and supporting our projects
and programs
including us several software engineers
since this is an informatics forum i
thought i'd focus in a little bit on
some of the technology this is uh
obviously lacking a lot of detail but um
we have a couple of full stack
developers on our team uh a senior data
analyst who has um
know something like eight to nine epic
certifications so can do front-end and
back-end work uh we work with a lot of
apis and fire resources and so forth
we're increasingly moving a lot of our
solutions to the cloud and setting up
sort of scalable architectures and so
forth
and then this is just sort of a very
quick snapshot a lot of the acronyms and
things are not going to make sense to to
you all but um this is a slide from an
internal presentation we're starting to
count the number of lives touched with
our programs
as well as supporting both the
healthcare you know delineating which
projects directly benefit clinical care
which ones are more research driven and
then they all have a blend of those two
things to them
and then we've also are working in
conjunction with our
ctsi uh here at wake forest too to
enable some organizational-wide tools so
not just building individual
applications but supporting things like
secure text messaging this started off
as a as a
digital communications course started
off as an initiative to support research
and then we quickly have on-boarded
clinical operations in our education
uh our cme office uh we're helping them
with uh these capabilities as well so
we've kind of embedded the center within
some
some core uh services for for the
organization
and then i promised that i would cover a
couple of projects
at a very high level just to give you a
sense of the things that that we're
doing
so empath
is a
project uh the the the pi's on the
project dave miller and aj derrod this
is a culmination of over a decade of
research
started off as being sort of
computer-based desktop-based uh research
that has now moved on to a tablet
uh it's a
in some ways functionality is where
we're shifting
the empath platform
as our ehr functionalities our native
ehr functionalities
improve and take over some of these
services but this is a preventative gap
closing app so this is something that we
hand over to patients when they register
in our clinics
and it speeds up the intake process but
with that we're also identifying
preventative care gaps so things like
colorectal cancer screening and lung
cancer screening and so on and so forth
and so we've now rolled this out to over
20 clinics here we
also are involved in a large research
study with unc or university of north
carolina and they're they're using our
application as well
and the beauty of the empath platform
which is now spread to about six five or
six different use cases
is that it works in both a
fee-for-service and a value-based world
so no matter
who who you're talking to or which
accountants and so forth you can make
the case that
this is beneficial from a financial
standpoint which is important for
sustainability
uh another project that has uh
that we've accelerated that has taken up
a lot of our time and for for good
reasons is the electronic frailty index
so this is interesting because this is
all used this is using all secondary
data so we're pulling
over 50 data elements out of the
electronic health record and you can see
those the the sort of buckets of those
data element types down in the lower
left-hand side
we pull those data elements out for our
patients that are 55 and older and we
actually are able to calculate an
objective measure index of their
cognitive and physical
ability
or function and so what that allows you
to do is to set up targeted outreach
programs to provide kind of more
personalized care and services
to people who are more vulnerable
vulnerable and frail and we actually
mobilized this kind of unexpectedly in
the early days of the pandemic
by identifying patients who had visits
scheduled or should have had visits
scheduled that were canceled and then we
set up special clinics where they were
you know folks were spaced out and we
took precautions to make that
face-to-face visit as safe as possible
if they needed to have a face-to-face
visit in lieu of telehealth or some
other way and then we also used it in
the early days to help prioritize uh
vaccines when when they were hard to
come by and make sure that we were
getting them to the right patients first
um
efi is is
strongly predictive so what you're
looking at here and this is uh you see
the publication citation down below
um nick and kate uh published this that
it it really very clearly stratifies
populations
and we sort of classify them based on
the index score between
uh fit pre-frail and frail
and so you can see when you measure
things like healthcare utilization
metrics like healthcare encounters and
ed visits and so forth um it it cuts
them out uh it separates them out very
clearly and then injurious falls and
other things as well
and then importantly uh when we hope i
it helps identify those who might
need to have things like advanced care
planning and other
end-of-life discussions
put in place so we can identify those
care gaps as well
just a couple more slides so as a
you know deputy director of the center
one of the things i constantly have to
do is think uh more than probably what i
would like to about our financials and
so um
my main objective in doing so is
figuring out how to keep a lot of these
programs sustainable beyond the initial
grant funding or the initial
organizational internal investment and
so we've partnered up with our
technology transfer group and a couple
of other key partners some behavioral or
some healthcare economists to help us
think about
revenue streams for some of these
platforms and projects to keep them keep
them going so we don't have to rely on
uh ex you know completely on federal
funding and so we use things like the pr
private marketing framework and business
model canvas and some other sort of more
what you think of as innovation type
frameworks to figure out how to create
sustainable business models and revenue
streams to keep us going
and then i sort of alluded to this
earlier uh
it's very important to think about not
just where we are but where the
healthcare in general is going and so as
we think about the business model and
how we reach out to
interact with patients it's important to
think about it both from where we are
today which is volume based or fee for
service
and where we're going
and so thinking about value-based care
and capitated
care and so we started mapping out this
is just four of our marquee projects
and sort of just kind of looking at them
through that lens to understand how we
can grow the programs or change
direction with the programs going
forward
so just uh just right to wrap up and
then get to some questions so we've got
a portfolio here again of over 20 or so
projects a lot of them the challenge for
us is bandwidth as i alluded to earlier
um
some things we've we've sunset others
have have grown and they're they're
scaling quite rapidly and
so we're trying to grow the center
capabilities to match that as much as
possible uh but that is a constant
challenge for us we're playing a role as
a key translational catalyst so if you
remember that gold arrow in the middle
of what that one one slide visual the
problem solution value framework that's
really where we see ourselves as is
moving things
faster down that translational spectrum
and then uh
our health system is is evolving growing
we had a strategic partnership with
atrium health which is a large large
health system that was formalized 18
months ago and so we're increasingly
finding folks from all across all of our
geographies and all of our organization
to help us
uh
really accomplish as much as we can for
all of our patients and not just here in
whistling
and then this is a little equation i
always flash up so often the the the end
slide in my talk so um the one thing we
always think about is the impact we're
making and for us that's that's the
value and then the scale um so it's a
permutation or a combination of those
things so in some ways if you look after
your research lenses your effect size
and your sample size but
we are constantly re-evaluating and
against some key metrics on our impact
so with that i will stop sharing the
slides
and i'm uh happy to to answer any any
questions let me check the chat here
i don't see any in the chat um
but people can feel free to either speak
up or
um
uh type into the chat um i didn't
realize actually that all three of
today's speakers were femia when we
started um
and um actually empath um i um i
um the empath uses fire right
um yeah yep
yeah we
have
good doctor
i i um you know i attended the um
the fire
app challenge or whatever it's called at
the amia meeting last year and um one of
the presentations there was um on empath
i think awesome yeah confusing
you probably saw aj yeah we i think we
we got second place in that in that
competition um yeah as we build out
these scalable solutions we are
constantly evaluating um you know eight
different apis and fire and we've
migrated a lot right like as those
resources mature um we move them over
and take over some of these uh
you know custom apis that we've built
and so on and so forth but we've been
very lucky we've had folks like josh
mandel um
come and speak to us so and help us see
some opportunities for using fire
resources
yeah great
i see that rohit has his hand up
here can you hear me
yep yep
awesome great uh eric thanks so much for
presenting i guess i have a more
foundational question um
in that how did you get an academic
health center
to focus and
somewhat fund a
innovation lab because when i because
when i traditionally think of academic
centers i think of much slower moving
innovation and there's a lot of
different stakeholders to involve
what was that process like
do you think any of it is repeatable
elsewhere
yeah i think um there were a lot of sort
of
drivers for it i think one of the main
ones is that we're a large research
entity and um
i think you know again as as research
was carried out and was successful and
demonstrated benefits um there were
options lost to quickly implement that
on our own home turf and we were seeing
some things being implemented very well
in other organizations and so i think
that sort of highlighted the need for
some mechanisms to really
one look at these projects from the
get-go and figure out you know from an
implementation science framework and
others
you know how should we be carrying out
our research so that once we prove out
it works we can move it into practice
quickly and so on um two i think uh you
know i came here because of the
opportunity the timing and when i
interviewed folks i saw a lot of uh
great substrate around like a bunch of
great projects ready for acceleration
and i thought we could kind of stack the
deck and have some wins early but then i
also saw support behind those projects
and programs and executive level support
as well so
um that's sort of a wishy-washy answer
of like all the right things aligned at
the right time for me
and what i was looking for um but and
then i'll give jeff williamson dr
williamson my my boss the director of
the center i'll give him credit he did a
ton of heavy lifting and by the time i
heard about the opportunity i just
happened to hear about it at the right
time and he had won a lot of those
battles early
great i also see that
her hand up
hi eric thanks so much for the
presentation you've mentioned executive
sport and a few key items but do you
have a an evaluation framework that you
use for prioritizing what what must be
tons of ideas that come your way
yeah so i think
this is actually a very important
question um and just to be quick about
it because i know that we've just got a
little bit of time so intake is super
important the filters you put on and how
you you know the things that come in
your pipeline and how you pick and
choose which is challenging we know we
leave really good ideas out just outside
because we just have limited bandwidth
and resources but we do have a
prioritization rubric
over the last couple years i've been
here we've really focused on formalizing
the process so we've got an intake
process that starts in redcap and a lot
of the things that people input on that
initial intake full end up getting
populated into a scoring a scoring
matrix and then we sit down and talk
with people uh get uh you know more more
details about their idea and then try to
score it accurately and if nothing else
i give we give folks feedback very
valuable feedback uh about where we
think they are what direction they could
go and so even when they say you know we
can't work on this at this time
we still try to connect them with
resources to move their things along so
but that intake process is super
important and it is really hard because
there's lots of great stuff that comes
in the door
ah thank you
great um okay well we are just about at
the hour i um i think it's great um to
hear
um all the um
wonderful things that our program alumni
are doing and and hopefully this will
inspire um
students in the program and uh show them
the
uh
various varying pathways that um uh
becoming formally trained in uh
informatics will bring
so um i think i will wrap up the uh
conference at this point
and um
for those